[Musique]
moi je trouve que c'est super important
d'avoir ben bova jeun et
mon docteur ces meurtres
du coup c'est trop bien genre la passe
comme si j'avais tout sans genre salut
les halles fans salut les parents voilà
une petite vidéo pour vous dire que
j'étais chimie biologique est le
meilleur et je me suis refait le fiom
voilà le fuel est tout neuf j'ai le fun
fun de bittorrent est là il est
magnifiquement fiom jeu l'adorent et ben
voilà le siphon m'intéresse c'est le
parc naturel protégé quoi cela il ya des
animaux en voie de disparition qui vive
je vous fais des bisous et vieux le fia
où on compte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 c'est bien ma
fille
[Applaudissements]
aux [ __ ] mais que ça sent bon mais
mon billet mais ça sent bon c'est quoi
que témoin c'est le one million c'est ça
c'est ça hein permettant le parfum de
charron
babydoll jesse may be blood diamond dogs
quoi faire
vas-y haut
québécois
yeah
où
alors
[Musique]
maintenant
et pourquoi
et vous
ico
j'arrive pas enlever ses colombes à dire
contre toi j'arrive pas
[Rires]
question d'organiser une réaction